Poland not a nuclear weapons state but
until recently the country had enough
uranium to make about 18 bombs it was
fuel for Poland's only operating nuclear
research reactor I was invited to watch
a u.s. funded operation to remove fuel
from the Polish Institute of atomic
energy 30 kilometers southeast of Warsaw
built at the height of the Cold War the
institute's reactor ran on highly
enriched uranium supplied by the Soviet
Union this is the kind of uranium
required to make a nuclear weapon after
the Soviet Union fell the uranium was
stranded here so three years ago the US
government began to negotiate for its
return to Russia where it will be made
into a fuel with lower enrichment safer
fuel will also be supplied to the Polish
Institute so it can continue to run its
reactor over a weekend in late September
I watched the last of the fuel make its
way out of Poland security was tight we
weren't allowed to discuss the dates of
the shipment or release any information
about it until it got to its destination
it was the fifth shipment made over the
past year the route was complicated
first the shipment was taken by truck to
a rail yard near Warsaw and loaded onto
a train from there it travelled to the
Baltic port of get Dania this was one of
the smaller shipments it only carried
enough fuel for two or so nuclear
weapons but the Polish National Police
weren't taking any chances when we got
to the port they were out in force the
crates were loaded onto a Russian ship
that would take them to Murmansk from
there the fuel travels by train to a
reprocessing plant in Siberia where it
will be made into fuel that is safer to
use
globally over a hundred research
reactors run on uranium that could be
used in a weapon over the next few years
the US hopes to conduct more shipments
like these in order to reduce the risk
of nuclear terrorism